-Looking good, bud.
Welcome back to the show.
Thank you for coming back.
Congratulations.
You and your lovely wife, Claire
Danes, are expecting a baby.
-What?
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Am I right? [ Laughs ]
I'm surprising you. Yes.
-Wow, great.
-Surprise! Yeah, yeah.
That's fantastic.
-Yes, thank you.
-Third baby.
Are you ready for number three?
-No.
-No?
-No, no.
I mean, I'm very happy about it.
-Of course, yeah, yeah, yeah.
But not prepared.
-But not ready.
Are you ever?
Are you ever ready?
-No.
-I personally feel like in
my limited experience that you
can only prepare as far as
the arrival of the baby and
everything after that is just --
just a blank.
-How old are
your other two kids?
-10 and 4.
-Is that correct?
-Yeah. Yeah, yeah.
I had him when I was 8.
[ Laughter ]
-Exactly.
Do they understand what Dad does
for a living or Mom?
-Uh.. [ Laughs ]
No, no. No, no, no. I was
thinking, do I understand?
-Yeah, that's kind of -- Yeah.
I'm not sure if my kids know.
A little bit.
-They don't care.
-Yeah. Have you showed them
any of your movies?
-Well, there's not many that
would be...
-Appropriate.
-...appropriate.
[ Laughter ]
I did show them
"Ella Enchanted."
I made one kids movie.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-That's a big deal.
-I know. It's a great film.
And people loved it
when they were kids.
And now, those people have
all grown up.
And that's kind of depressing
for me.
[ Laughter ]
-Did your kids know it was you
in the movie?
-No. Well, the older one still
couldn't care less.
And the younger one, we got
halfway through the movie,
and I was watching him.
And eventually I said,
"You know, that's me.
That's Daddy in the movie."
He had no idea,
which was very sweet,
which was maybe a testament
to my acting.
Or not.
[ Laughter ]
-No, you were that
into the role.
Do they visit you on
"Law & Order"?
-No, I was not that
into the role.
-You're like a method --
"That's not you, Dad."
-"Shut up, son."
[ Laughter ]
Take it in. Take it in.
-Daddy's speaking.
Daddy has a monologue. Please.
Do they go to "Law & Order"?
-They have, yeah.
-They've been to the set?
-They've been to the set --
not to the iconic --
not to the offices and all that
stuff and the courtroom.
But to the -- when we film, you
know, the courthouse steps,
which I guess is
kind of iconic --
-Of course.
-You know, come down the steps.
-Just to go root for Dad?
-No. Just because, honestly,
because we have Pop Tarts.
[ Laughter ]
-They love Pop Tarts.
-It dawned on me like the fourth
time they came, yeah.
-Yeah. You could just get
Pop Tarts for your house.
[ Laughter ]
-I could. I could.
But then they wouldn't come
to visit me at work.
[ Laughter ]
-Before we talk "Law & Order,"
the Oscar nominations
just came out.
And you were telling me that you
have a pretty personal
connection to one
of the nominees.
-I do. One of the front runners,
I think.
Yeah, it's an odd story.
-No, I love this story.
Please tell it.
-So, this was several years ago.
I was getting a wig made,
as you do.
For professional purposes.
[ Laughter ]
And the guy, you know,
they wrap your head in, like,
plastic wrap.
It's a whole process.
Anyway, he said,
"I don't know if
I'm going to do this in time."
He called me back the next day
and said, "Good news.
Your head is exactly the same
shape and size as somebody else
that I have worked on,
another actor.
And I have the mold of
their head at home.
So this is going to be a cinch
for me."
And I said, "Who's that?"
And, you know, you're probably
thinking
it's Brendan Fraser or whatever.
But it's Cate Blanchett.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Cate Blanchett has your same
size head.
That's fantastic.
-It bodes well for me.
-Are you honored? I mean, that's
so good, both of you guys.
She should be honored as well.
Oh, my God.
I never see both of you in
the same room at the same time.
[ Laughter ]
That's wild to know that you
have the same size head --
-It's very weird.
-Yeah, that's so --
Alright.
Let's get into "Law & Order."
This is a big deal.
Did you ever think you were
going to be this New York?
-No, I didn't, and I've lived
here for 15 years.
And I still didn't feel entitled
to that.
-It's iconic, "Law & Order."
-Yeah.
-It's very, very New York.
In fact, we found out you're not
the first family member
to act on "Law & Order."
-Mm.
-Your wife, Claire Danes,
this was her TV debut.
-Yeah.
-1992.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Isn't that odd?
That was her first --
Now you're in it.
-It's so strange, isn't it?
-It's got to be strange.
-Yeah. But then again, it's not
because, you know, every actor,
every New York actor that I'm
sure that comes through here
or that you see on Broadway
or whatever
has been on "Law & Order."
-That's correct.
-Literally every actor.
Some of them 18 times.
-Yes.
-But it's great.
-It's a lot of people's
first acting roles.
What was your first acting role?
-Some of us, it's their last.
-That's true.
[ Laughter ]
A lot of -- Yeah, exactly yeah.
I would love to play a dead body
on "Law & Order."
[ Laughter ]
I would love to.
-Please.
I think you'd be just right.
[ Laughter ]
-Thank you so much. Wow.
But you -- What was -- Do you
remember your first role?
-My first role was in England
obviously.
Well, maybe not obviously.
It was on a show called
"Trial and Retribution,"
which is like the Anglicized
version of "Law & Order."
[ Laughter ]
-"Trial and Retribution."
That just sounds a little bit --
-Donk, donk.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
That's the theme song?
-Yes.
-Donk, donk. Yes.
[ Laughter ]
It's that much better
than our "Law & Order."
Can you tell everyone who you
play on "Law & Order"?
-I play Nolan Price.
He's the assistant district
attorney...
[ Cheers and applause ]
-...under --
I'm in Sam Waterston's office.
He's my boss now. He's moved up.
It's super cool.
-That's the best.
Donk, donk. I'm never going to
forget that. That's funny.
I want to show a clip. Here's
Hugh Dancy in "Law & Order."
Take a look at this.
-We had a deal.
-I changed my mind.
-You signed a cooperation
agreement.
It's binding and enforceable.
-[ Scoffs ]
-There will be consequences.
Do you not understand that?
-Max is willing to plead guilty,
reckless endangerment.
-That's not on the table
anymore.
You don't seem to hear
what I'm saying.
I will revoke your bail,
send you back to Rikers,
and move forward on a charge of
manslaughter.
-They're just blowing smoke.
-No, we're serious.
-Well, I'm sorry. I can't do it.
-Come on. Hugh Dancy, everybody!
"Law & Order" airs Thursdays
at 8:00 p.m. on NBC,
and it's available the next day
on Peacock.
More "Tonight Show" after
the break. Stick around.
Thank you, buddy.